[Music]
you know what I didn't like about Django
Unchained what four or five hundred uses
would be inward what no we are we gonna
hold this movie about the slave era to
our modern political correctness
standards like one of the white people
movie supposed to call black people
disappointments we're gonna use
something innocuous so that we don't get
any historical accuracy you know where
there's a difference between historical
accuracy and overkill man use that word
like three times a sentence in that's
not an exaggeration at all when we talk
about historical accuracy let's talk
about Jackie Browns talk about affection
okay let's talk about these are both set
in the 90s and shot a 90s the single
most PC era that's ever existed and the
n-words all over both of those movies I
mean a pulp fiction Tarantino since the
word like it's a stutter and this is it
to samuel objects in space and that
guy's got to have titanium balls no I
think people are just too sensitive
about words these days people are too
sensitive about some words these days
the n-word they're not being too
sensitive
that word is toxic only one word more
controversial than that which is Dudek
you do this is all on camera right
believe you just said that
Tarantino could say the n-word to Samuel
Jackson then why can't I say the Nile
origin swamp where is it not include
that word it's apocalyptic right Safford
Sam Jackson had a conversation as Sam
Jackson like he's your buddy
okay saying that LM mother Jackson the
point is do you think he was done with
movie B's offended certainly wasn't
offended by the paycheck
dude everybody worked for scale in that
movie it was made for eat million
dollars and how that probably would the
GIMP don't cost anything come on
I have a gimp here by 5:00 p.m. with
accessories the point is about Django
Unchained I didn't like the scene
another take
Django - the mine no what's wrong with
that everything feels tacked on
Tarantino indulges his acting but again
playing an Australian slave driver all
right
the scenes only there so they can pay
off the horrible things James Django was
the hero Oh was he was he really I mean
let's remember he's coming back to save
as well that's a noble thing yeah it's
Noble but think about what he has to do
to save his wife
she transforms into this method actor
and becoming a black bounty on her so
finally makes Uncle Tom look like Snow
White
then you had to convince Lee a number to
cap it right but even after he's
convinced DiCaprio and everybody else he
still looks that other black guy get
Lynch I'm stopping it
even though Christoph Waltz is there
I've offered to pay his own good money
to save the guy still let it happen and
the only way that pays all office
there's something that happens in the
story later on where you can then be
vouched for by slaves you can say you
know he's not with us or he's not what
the scene where he's being led to the
mine yes you just allowed all this
suffering right and you let a man die a
horrible death just in the event you
were being led away to a remote mine
just in the event other slavery with you
that could vouch for your story just in
the event the white people believe your
story and let you go then maybe you can
bring up and you can go see your wife
again
and say in the end Django was the thing
he was pretending to be and say I'd like
to see you say that to a group of black
people sometime don't really know any
black people that's racist you don't
really know when you've likely believe
it but I'm telling everybody about it
[Music]